hi I'm Greg I'm John and I'm Jetta Kawai
javi Kawai is my brother from the same
mother easier today to do the
transformer the last night trailer
number 2 reaction with us this was
requested the first one a lot of
requests came in all at once
Denzel Diaz was the first one ooh he is
Adele Washington's brother it's actually
Denzel Washington out of wedlock Mexican
child oh that's my yes end of this
improv game I watched all the
Transformers movies good yes so far okay
oh good you're keeping on topping I'm on
top okay I'm good well I've seen all the
other trailers for this movie it looks
great it looks like the best movie I've
ever been made yeah that was ever why
that doesn't begin Morty's man will get
away with anything I've never said that
as a kid yes you know I'm okay
my world fell apart look at the camera
look at me
white to normal school there's no rain
Jersey thank you evening with far as
you're concerned my boyfriend how long
[Laughter]
if they you run right girl
you need to carry a comment don't expect
any effect on please throw like a girl
bicycle
you are you're mine you're a little site
that think you're better it's okay to be
a kid little j.lo funny to keep inhaling
I'm gonna have life depends on then
fight like a girl
yeah I saw are you girl goes real one
[Music]
damn
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
amusing
Oh
there are you got your mouse on lock the
closes right now
[Music]
well think about what you did well you
can always trust Michael Bay to up the
ante with every yeah transformer that's
a peepers are [ __ ] insane this oqd
can always count on the trailers to
always look great yeah well I enjoyed
the last one I might be in the minority
on that I enjoy climb on in the minority
with you like we're related yeah I
actually that was one of the feel I kind
of enjoy back you what could he look
like he was actually having fun like
Mark Wahlberg looked like he was having
fun in the movie in this world they
wouldn't take himself too seriously and
I think this one is a departure from the
other transformers in that they're
showing a girl as a strong character as
opposed to Megan Fox is on the edge of a
motorcycle they're a thing and out like
now it had a female empowerment so to
speak you know it could be laid before
the trailer because they literally
cannot Google an underage child guy not
allowed to dude I don't know it's
exactly stranger things but with
transformers it's got a bunch of nerdy
dudes who come up with friend a female
badass character and Mark Wahlberg is
like the sheriff character you saw
strangers name yes I serve I don't
believe it okay keep I'm suddenly
becoming responsible for getting
involved in the big kid now I didn't
feel I didn't feel like the sci-fi music
did okay I didn't look it's all a
stranger thing I didn't see the stranger
thing thing but only because it's like
the group of kids wasn't what it stood
out to me what stood out to me was this
little girl who's standing up for her
what she believes in and she developing
this bond with Mark Wahlberg so it's
closer to Logan for me than it is to
stranger things in that respect you
really got it stranger things at all
they look like they don't look like 2010
nerdy children they look like 1980s
nerdy kids with a token black kid in
there and then they and they have the
one girl who they like they all kind of
have a crush on you know well there's a
family girl I'm fairly certain those
kids are depart from the movie early on
and I know becomes becomes focused on
her and Mark Wahlberg together I could
see the Logan vibe you're talking about
you know we won't doing like a PSA at
the beginning of this trip she was like
talking directly into the camera I
tell winces format of this this looked
like half like I'm just gonna tell you
about the movie and a half here's some
clip I feel like that was written the
fourth wall said like the opening of the
film I've got something you see right at
the start just to get you up to speed
with where the world is at what's going
on because it's almost like it's
post-apocalyptic yeah about it'll begin
and we like from the flash film was
still kind of modern and said in our
times this is like okay [ __ ] has gone
awry this is in the future like 20 years
from the earth Markel were saying so
maybe 10 years from you know what tears
a little longer that's true but are we
sure to write it go officially it's got
more facial hair than last time it says
when my daughter's dead now or something
I really thought he was going to have a
chance at the top daughter did I feel
like this is the fifth Transformers
movie of course they're going to start
aping all kinds of things that are more
popular than what transformers used to
be like you know like we talked about
stranger things in the first trailer
erection like yeah and I don't think
like transformers is a toy for children
and I'm not opposed to them bringing in
kids as some kind of focus it's like as
much as as much as there are things I
want to roll my eyes well I actually
think this could be a cool direction to
take this in I mean it's got all the big
crazy like sci-fi world [ __ ] that we
love it's got you know gruff guy spunky
girl that we love it's got kid adventure
together that we love right now like
it's like everything you love right now
but in a transformers package and it
worth is the main girl in spend hey you
little JLo ethnic thank you she's little
g-well she looks more ethnically
ambiguous to me but he called her JLo so
I assume she's Hispanic which is cool in
its own because now you have like a
minority in the lead which is awesome
yeah you know as opposed to a completely
whitewashed chest so this is doing all
the politically correct things
yeah was it a you know hope you have an
Hispanic girl minority at the front and
it's a female and it's a kid who's like
like you're showing that little girls
can be strong too
yeah I don't mind a kid touch to it
especially because you know kids really
love this franchise and it started off
as a cartoon so it makes sense to
actually have some real kids be part of
the Central Park
the movie I just hope it's 2 hours and
35 minutes and overblown like the other
one that's usually what Lisa da di delay
the last film was 2 hours and 45 I mean
most Michael Bay releasing 2 being
really really long I mean if you watch
that voice to that movie was like 150
minutes long that's what I that's the
one thing I thought throughout this
trailer was they're showing like so many
settings in so many places so many big
situations I'm like how long and sick is
this move like where to start where does
it go like the one thing all the dreams
and tired
came to one of the few comments arrives
I noticed with all the Transformers
movies is there's weird humor and people
seem to not like and this trailer had
some of its weird humorous touches in
there because there's a lot more humor
in the Transformers films when the
trailers ever let on but they just don't
ever quite land but here it seemed to be
kind of working little JLo little
Dinobot working at is like car
construction company here's something
like that I don't know - going on it
doesn't cute like stuff that for like
jokes that are about personalities are
good if you're just going to show me
Robo testicles again you know I'll check
out that yeah but having two kids I
think I mean despite like me sounding
like I'm annoyed by the stranger thing
it's like I feel like when something is
so apparently in my face it can kind of
bother me that's not to say I don't
think he can't work though because it
could bring back to that like wonder
like I might gain a stranger doesn't
feel like an 80s movie to me whatsoever
and that's what was prominent in the
eighties kids films with these group of
kids who you know get together and take
on some kind of adventure that's bigger
than themselves I just want to review
stranger things I don't know that they
got me interested again so good for the
it started again Transformers movie
trailer comes out we go we have hope
this time and then we land disappointed
by the Kansas or some YouTube video that
had come out some time ago that showed
transformers two and three side-by-side
the trailers and how the trailers were
exactly the same thing because it was
like I'm what we call it a trick or a
method that gets you hooked for some
reason to this emotional hook worth like
all the perfect visuals
put together to get to make you believe
that it might be different this time but
it might be better but it don't work and
it in it and it lightened for me for
for so I enjoyed perforce like I went in
knowing that it was just going to you
know be a silly actions s and I thought
I can say empirically that I'm more
interested in this than any of the ones
since the second one like I saw the
third round like this looks like it
could be cool again that didn't carry
through and the same with the fourth one
this one like I felt like in the third
one I didn't even see it there well I I
stopped going after the second one
because the Sega was like so long and I
she's kind of boring after oil and it's
going to get tired of it I was like I
they're all these moving parts and all
these robots codes the same I don't get
why they're fighting on earth all right
well you can subscribe to the real
rejects jhanas reasons to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram as a social media
manager of Blum House and you could
follow jammy Kauai on the jab eco a
channel where he does javi Kuwait things
youtube.com slash Gebbie tube chubby -
that's a new one for the American videos
server that's where I have it Jeffy
Gabby - Gabby - because you can look at
them you know it sound like a porn site
right it's not